هناك تجمعات داخل الحديقه التي نقف امامها
من المتظاهرين
وقسمها رجال الشرطه الى جزئين جزء
مسانديه ترامب والجزء الاخر لمناوي ترامب
وكانت هناك مناوشات صباح اليوم بين
الطرفين ولكن نفهم
ان الشرطه او راينا الشرطه لان نقف امامهم
فصلوا بين الجزئين بالرغم من تبادل او
تلاسم اعضاء هذه المظاهرات هذه المظاهرات
المفروض ان تبدا الساعه الثانيه عشر
بتوقيت جرينتش لذلك هي في بدايتها
وسترتفع الاعداد ولكن
رجال الشرطه
بجاكيتات الزرقاء يقفون على اهبه
الاستعداد للفصل بين الطرفين
والشرطه كثيره هنا جدا جدا جدا وفي شوارع
في في مركبات وحافلات ينتظرون وقوع اي
اضطرابات للقدوم الى هنا وشركات الاعلام
التي نقف هنا معها جميعها
جاءت باقنعه من كل انحاء العالم الغازات
الملايين الجموع يتابعون نعم من امام
محكمه من هاتن الجنائيه كان معنا مدير
مكتب العربيه في نيويورك طلال الحاج شكرا
جزيلا لك